If you're Pando, you might be able to shine even if you're like me
[Music] I
definitely
don't want to work I
'm scared
I'm scared of society I'm sorry I'm getting carried away I'm
scared of reality
I
'm tired from talking too much with people today, so
I'm going home I'm sorry, that's the guitar,
right?  Let's make a song and make a
major debut as a high school student
Bocchi Drop Broadcast starts on October 8th
That's right
[music] If you
study hard,
you'll forget how to play the bass I don't have money right now, so I'll treat you to a
friend It's only 2 o'clock
Broadcast starts on October 8th Now that I have enough money, I'm
going to live on grass I
fell in love at first sight when I saw seniors live on the street
[Music]
I love interacting with private people
I want to see the quota too much I need to work harder
You
're getting more and more fun
Bocchi Drop Broadcasting starts on October 8th
I wanted to join a bond band and be my senior's daughter
Deeper than my friends